hey guys how's it going it's justine and
today we're doing an ask ij episode
which is
short for ijustine if you're new here i
asked you guys on twitter and on
instagram
to ask me some questions so that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna answer these
and i feel like most of the questions
that i got were all about the new iphone
what do i think about the new iphone 8
what are the latest iphone 8 rumors what
do i think of the leaked designs and
truthfully at this point
i've kind of stopped looking at the
rumors because it's all
just sort of a bunch of just nonsense
it's all recirculated old rumors that i
feel like that have just been
beat to death it's gonna be a full on
screen there's gonna be a touch sensor
on the back no just kidding it's now in
the front
i can't quite keep up and until there's
something new and actual crazy hard
evidence i'm just gonna kind of take a
step back
maybe two steps back until we get some
evidence i need more than these
fake photoshop images and most of the
stuff that i've been seeing
it's all looking like not good news for
example apple has just weeks to solve
the iphone 8
touch id dilemma there's been a bunch of
reports that apple is having trouble
trying to get the touch id to work on
the full oled screen and that was one of
the big issues that samsung was also
having which is why they ended up having
their fingerprint sensor on the back who
knows we don't know these are all rumors
i need troops i don't want any more lies
in my life cut them out speaking of
rumors i say this but yet
i'm still reading it this is something
that i thought was actually super
interesting iphone 8 may feature
rear-facing
3d laser for improved autofocus and ar
you guys may remember that apple
announced their ar kit which i've seen
so many various demos of
and it looks super cool augmented
reality is one of my favorite things now
i like vr but vr i feel like takes you
out of your element i like taking what
you already have
and improving it yet adding this other
crazy layer that otherwise would not be
possible
if it wasn't for ar so augmented reality
huge fan super excited to see what apple
does with that so that definitely would
make sense with this 3d laser
to be able to get a sense of your room
and your surroundings and be able to
accurately portray whatever it is that
that ar kit will be able to
do excited iphone 8 will come in four
colors
what including a new mirror like
exterior and here's the thing you know i
was super excited about having that jet
black iphone but i have a case on it i
have to have a case on it
i drop it i have a case on it it's such
a slick surface that it's so hard to
hold on to
but this looks cool although that's just
the case
but we get the point there's also been
some rumors about some things not
actually being ready for launch so there
was a pool that i saw that said would
you rather
the phone launch without these features
activated and then later be activated or
have the phone be delayed i'd rather
have the phone and then those features
come later there's been other reports of
people saying that they're also having
trouble
with wireless charging i don't know i
don't really know what to believe let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and i look forward to reading those
but i guess we'll just move on to our
next question because there were just so
many questions
that you guys had about the iphone 8.
and really the only thing i can say
is i'm just waiting for the truth logan
wants to know how many pets i've had in
my life i've had a lot of pets in my
life
maddie is my first dog that is my very
own that i have 100
well 50 pretty much control over because
my sister has him almost just as much as
i do
but it's pretty much our dog it's our
baby growing up we had dogs
we had cats we had hamsters we had
guinea pigs
but my mom and dad did all the work
pretty much i mean i would sometimes
feed the dog
we also had chickens i at times would
have to go feed the chickens
give them some scraps of food pick the
eggs sometimes feed the cats but
overall like my parents did everything
and i had no concept until these past
two years of how hard it is to raise an
animal
and they raised three children plus
animals just
a lot of stuff i still to this day don't
know how my parents
have done all of the things that they
did for us it still is
by far the most impressive thing ever so
mom dad thank you
also my grandparents i mean they always
watched us too so
man just i i can barely handle myself
first asking if i'd marry the dancing
hot dog i definitely would this stupid
hot dog named
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean is it is it a meme at this point
it's a snapchat filter but it's this
dancing hot dog the first time i saw it
was like this is hilarious i'm so amused
i'm still slightly amused a week later i
don't think you guys are
or my sister she's very sick of the hot
dog but i still think it's funny
i'm still quite amused speaking of my
sister she is asking me
what do you think about me uh i think
you're great you're fantastic and you're
extremely sassy and what were we
listening to the other day in the car
we were actually listening to an
audiobook on audible it's pretty much
the only thing that i do listen to in
the car if i'm not listening to music
i'm listening to an audiobook because i
love to read but i don't have time to
read i'm sure i can make time but it's
much easier
driving in traffic and listening to a
book because i'm basically doing two
things at the same time i'm driving and
i'm reading and yes i know
you're just waiting for it audible.com
ijustine where you guys can get a 30 day
free trial and a free audiobook so you
guys can choose anything that you'd like
and here are my two recommendations for
the month i do have these books in a
physical form too
because i like to support my friends i
get the audio version and i get the
analog
version so that i can also put these on
my bookshelf so the first book that
we're gonna talk about
is by lizzie velasquez the best part
about audible
is a lot of times the authors actually
read the books so in this book lizzy
does read her book to you so you feel
like you're listening to your best
friend talk to you
if you guys don't know lizzy she's a
youtuber an incredible motivational
speaker she's written several books
she's got an amazing documentary she's
toured the whole world
telling her story and now in her book
she tells way more than she's ever told
before
so being able to like hear her tell this
story and really feel what she's feeling
was amazing i feel like this book should
be recommended reading for parents
and kids before you go to school because
it talks so much about bullying and how
to deal with bullies
it also touches on a lot of more
in-depth things that i wasn't even
expecting and even though that i knew
these stories were going to be in this
book it was still kind of crazy to hear
lizzy tell the world for the first time
some of the struggles that she had been
going through that nobody had ever known
so lizzy i absolutely adore you and i
love you and i hope that everyone
does decide to listen to this book this
is crazy because lizzy just texted me
right now she said i had to contain
myself from watching your camera videos
because i want to buy everything you
talk about
this is crazy i'm legit making a video
how did she know i'm sending her a
picture this
is crazy so check out lizzie's book dare
to be kind she also has an incredible
documentary i feel like i'm pretty much
going to talk about lizzie this whole
video because she's just such an amazing
person
this book is called best seat in the
house and i'm just going to preface this
by saying
i don't know anything about wrestling i
don't know anything about wwe
i mean my extent of knowledge of
wrestling
is hulk hogan and the rock and also john
cena because i once bought a john cena
backpack at walmart so like
that's it i met justin fairly recently
when i was in pittsburgh for a tool
concert
and he was there doing the tool vip
experience and then he was heading off
to go do a book signing and i was like
oh
that's cool what's your book about so he
had briefly given me a quick rundown of
what it was about
this book is also read by justin and
again like i said having the authors
who are telling their own stories read
their books is by far the coolest thing
ever so much like lizzie's book that
dealt a lot with bullying justin also
dealt with so much of that in wwe which
so many people had
no idea about and clearly me i have
absolutely no idea because i i've never
watched wrestling in my life but the
book was so awesome because it
chronicled his entire life
leading up to his dream job and then
when he got his dream job the dream job
that he thought that he
really was in love with ended up turning
out to be slightly a nightmare
what i loved so much about his book is
you can clearly tell how passionate he
was about wrestling and being able to
take something that is your passion
and turn it into your job i have so much
respect for anybody that can do that
and he did it for so long like the crazy
travel schedules
that these people have to go through to
do wwe tours
like i complain about getting stuck in
the airport for like
five hours but yet imagine doing that
for 12 years non-stop
that's crazy i feel like if you're a
wrestling fan you're gonna absolutely
love
this book and even if you're not i know
nothing half the time i was like i'm not
even sure
who he's talking about but it's the
personal story and the personal
connection to something that he
absolutely loved and was able to make
that dream come true
that i felt super connected to and i
feel like you guys will also absolutely
love it as well
these are my two audible picks for this
month justin roberts best seat in the
house
and lizzie velasquez dare to be kind you
can use my link audible.com
ijustine so you can get a free book 30
day free trial and i think you guys will
absolutely love
justin and lizzy telling you their life
stories
that's so i'm still i'm still chatting
with lizzy like i can't believe it this
is so nuts
the next question is x3zg what do i like
of the most about playing minecraft on
pc or nintendo switch
the nintendo switch minecraft is
actually super cool they've got a really
awesome mario mod so you can kind of
play in this mario world so i did just
started playing the survival of that but
playing on a pc
it's where i started playing minecraft
so you really do get that full sense of
crafting because with
the console versions they kind of have
all the recipes made for you already so
you just kind of like collect the stuff
and then click what you want to make and
then you can make it so it's actually a
little bit easier
i'm still contemplating starting a
server
i miss it so much we'll see maybe this
fall when it's all across platforms so
no matter what you're on you can still
play on it
am i going to camp out for the next
iphone oh my god i hope not
man camping out for that iphone was the
longest
time of my life i'd say a day but it was
over two days
like 56 7 8 58 hours and i hope i never
have to do that again but would i do it
again yeah of course i would
think i'm crazy yes i am rouland's
asking if i got all of
my digital storage figured out and no
i haven't yet i think i may have a
solution and i'm extremely excited
about it so stay tuned there may be a
very fun collab
happening with that so cody wants to
know
what do i do when i have a creative
block that's hard because i feel like i
have
an ongoing list of things that i want to
do and things i want to make so when i
do have a creative block i kind of go to
that list and
see what i want to make i'll also
sometimes go back and watch some of my
old videos because that will sometimes
kind of stem
some sort of creativity where i'm like
man i remember when i was doing
this and i wished that i could have done
this but either the technology wasn't
there
or i didn't have the money to do it or i
didn't have access to a certain thing so
sometimes that helps me to kind of see
where i was
10 years ago and remember why did i
start doing this
what was it that i wanted to do back
then that i could potentially do now
that i wasn't able to i sometimes feel
like there's too many things that i want
to do and i just don't have the capacity
to do it all
i think that's all the questions i have
let's see if you guys have any other
questions feel free to leave them in the
comments below and i will see you guys
in my next video
[Music]
bye
you